digamos que tenemos un poco de ácido
clorhídrico y una solución de hidróxido
de sodio
sabemos que el ácido clorhídrico es un
ácido fuerte que se disocia en h + cl -
mientras que el hidróxido de sodio es
una base fuerte que en solución se
disocia en iones de sodio y iones
hidróxido pensemos en los productos para
esta reacción un producto sería h más y
h menos que al juntarlos forman h2o
entonces uno de nuestros productos es
agua y el otro producto se conforma de n
a más y cl - así que tenemos en el ac el
cloruro de sodio este es un ejemplo de
una reacción de neutralización en donde
un ácido reacciona con una base para
formar agua y una sal que en este caso
es cloruro de sodio
entonces pensemos en una solución acuosa
de cloruro de sodio si disolvemos un
poco de cloruro de sodio en agua
obtenemos una solución con cationes de
sodio y aniones cloruro ahora sabemos
que el ph del agua es 7 el ph del agua
es igual a 7 y sabemos que los iones de
sodio no reaccionan con el agua así que
no afectan el ph de la solución pero los
aniones cloruro pueden funcionar como
una base débil y tomarán un protón del
agua aunque eso no ocurrirá fácilmente
porque el any un cloruro cl - es la base
conjugada de hcl y sabemos que hcl es un
ácido muy fuerte entre más fuerte sea un
ácido más débil es la base conjugada así
que esta es una base conjugada muy
y no puede tomar protones del agua tan
fácilmente así que tampoco afecta el ph
y por lo tanto el ph de nuestra solución
de cloruro de sodio es igual a 7 ahora
cuando se ha formado una sal a partir de
un ácido fuerte y una base fuerte es
decir como el cloruro de sodio se formó
a partir de un ácido fuerte y una base
fuerte estas sales forman soluciones
neutras así que el ph debe ser igual a 7
ahora comparemos esta situación con la
sal que se forma a partir de un ácido
débil y una base fuerte de este lado
tenemos ácido acético que es un ácido
débil y después tenemos el hidróxido de
sodio que es una base fuerte en solución
tendremos n a más y h menos el hidróxido
tomará un producto
del ácido acético este protón así que h
más y h - forman h2o y ahora pensemos en
la sal que se forma si tomamos un protón
del ácido acético nos queda el ión
acetato de h3c o menos y también tenemos
iones de sodio así que el sodio puede
formar un enlace iónico con el acetato y
así formamos acetato de sodio que se
encuentra en solución acuosa ahora ya
sabemos que el ph del agua es 7 pero
vamos a ver qué es lo que tenemos en
solución tenemos cationes de sodio que
no reaccionarán con el agua así que no
afectan el ph pero los anones acetato si
reacción
entonces escribamos lo que sucede los
aniones acetato reaccionarán con el agua
ponemos nuestras flechas de equilibrio
el año nace tato es la base conjugada
del ácido acético así que funcionará
como una base de bronce de lowry y el
agua funcionará como un ácido de
brondsted lowry ahora el agua donará un
protón al acetato y si el acetato acepta
un protón formamos nuevamente el ácido
acético de h3c
h solamente agregamos un h a la unión
acetato y si el acetato ha tomado un
protón del h2o entonces nos queda o h -
y qué pasa con la solución bueno como el
año nace tato está presente aumenta la
concentración de iones hidróxido
así que el ph ya no es igual a 7
ahora el ph es mayor a 7 entonces una
solución acuosa de acetato de sodio
tendrá un ph mayor a 7 y esto tiene
sentido porque si tenemos una sal
formada a partir de un ácido débil y una
base fuerte la sal formará soluciones
básicas en donde el ph es mayor a 7
veamos un último ejemplo aquí tenemos un
ácido fuerte y una base débil
hcl es un ácido fuerte y el amoniaco es
una base débil entonces hcl se disocia
en h + y cl - si dona un protón al nh 3
el nh 3 se convierte en nh 4 más el ión
amonio y también tenemos algunos han
iones cloruro que interactúan y
únicamente con el amonio
así que tenemos cloruro de amonio como
nuestra sal ahora pensemos en una
solución acuosa de cloruro de amonio
nuevamente sabemos que el agua tiene un
ph de 7 hilos aniones cloruro no
afectarán el ph pero los iones amonio
nh4 más reaccionará con el agua y
afectará el ph tenemos nh4 + + h2o el
ión amonio funcionará como un ácido de
bronze de logre donar a un protón al
agua y el agua funcionará como una base
de bronx de lowry aceptará un protón así
que al tomar un protón h más del nh 4
más nos queda
nh 3 amoníaco y si agregamos un h más al
h2o entonces nos queda h 3 o más el
johnny drone ya que ocurre con la
solución bueno cómo aumentamos la
concentración de iones sidronio eso
provoca que el ph cambie y sea menor a 7
entonces tenemos una solución a ciudad
donde el ph es menor a 7 así que una
solución acuosa de cloruro de amonio
tendrá un ph menor a 7 entonces una base
que se forma a partir de un ácido fuerte
y una base débil nos dará una solución
ácida